هل تكون ساعه المحاسبه قد دقت
فعلا هنا في محكمه العدل الدوليه في لهاي
كل شيء يشي بان اسرائيل في مازق قانوني
غير
مسبوق فال المحكمه قبلت النظر في الدعوه
التي تتهم فيها جنوب افريقيا اسرائيل
بارتكاب جرائم اباده ضد سكان غزه
ب بالنسبه لايف دودي القاضي في محكمه
العدل الدوليه فان القرار الذي سيصدر عن
المحكمه كيفما كان سيكون له اثره الكبير
ولو بعد
حين الاجراءات الاستثنائيه هي قرارات
مستعجله تصدر عن المحكمه وهي ملزمه وتتعلق
في هذه الحاله بطلب جنوب افريقيا من
المحكمه اصدار قرار بوقف المعارك في هذه
القضيه القرار الذي ستتخذه المحكمه لصالح
او ضد دعوه جنوب افريقيا سيكون له اثره
الكبير لان المحكمه تمثل ثقل القانون ورفض
التنفيذ امر خطير
جدا لعل ذلك يفسر هذا الزخم الذي يحيط
بالقضيه 84 صفحه قدمتها جنوب افريقيا الى
المحكمه وثقت فيها تفاصيل ما وصفتها
بجريمه الاباده التي تشنها اسرائيل ضد
سكان غزه وبناء عليه لبت من المحكمه اصدار
امر فوري لاسرائيل بوقف
المعارك لكن ثمت مشكله فقرارات المحكمه
وان كانت ملزمه فهي لا تملك ادوات
التنفيذ قرارات محكمه العدل الدوليه ملزمه
لكن الدول يمكنها ان تتملص من تنفيذها حدث
هذا من قبل لكن يجب ان نعلم ان عدم احترام
قرار المحكمه له اثار كبيره على صوره
الدوله التي ترفض التنفيذ لعل هذا ما يفسر
القلق الذي ينتاب اسرائيل وحلفائها من
نتائج هذه الدعوه خاصه وان المحكمه اصدرت
خلال السنوات الاخيره حكمين في سياق مشابه
امرت فيهما كلا من روسيا وميانمار بوقف
اعمالهم
العسكريه على بعد كيلومترات من هنا محكمه
اخرى معنيه هي ايضا بما يحدث في فلسطين هي
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه الفرق بين محكمتين
ان محكمه العدل تحكم بين الدول لا بين
الافراد ولا تصدر مذكره اعتقال على اختلاف
اختصاص المحكمتين فان ما يحدث هنا يؤثر
بالتاكيد على ما سيقع هناك فدانه اسرائيل
امام محكمه العدل قد تسهم في اصدار مذكرات
اعتقال ضد
قادتها في محكمه
الجنايات منذ بدايه الحرب توصلت محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه بدعاوى من جهات كثيره
يعمل المحامي جيلد فير رفقه فريق من
المحامين الدوليين على تجميع الادله التي
سيقدمها للمدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه في الوقت الذي يتطلعون فيه للقرار
الذي سيصدر عن محكمه
العدل sud dev dece دعوى جنوب افريقيا
امام محكمه العدل تساعدنا امام محكمه
الجنايات لان المدعي العام الذي يمكن ان
يشع بانه معزول بسبب الدعم الغربي
لاسرائيل سيجد نفسه مدعوما بقرار الادانه
اذا صدر من محكمه
العدل هكذا يعلق المدافعون عن حقوق
الانسان امالا كبيره على هذه الدعوه يرجون
من خلالها ان تورق شجره العداله من
جديد محمد البقالي الجزيره
هاي